how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and it looks like venom could
be making his way to the mcu actually it
looks like venom might already be in the
marvel cinematic universe there's been a
lot of talk recently about venom and
spider-man crossing paths in some
universe sooner than later in fact venom
let there be carnage director andy
circus has said that spider-man and
venom will indeed go face to face
sometime in the future he told that to
ign the other day and what's really
curious about this is that we're getting
this information at the same time that
we're getting all of these rumors about
the venom let there be carnage
post-credit scene and i actually think
that we might have gotten a little
insight from tom hardy venom himself on
what spider-man no way home's
post-credit scene might actually be and
you guessed it i'm sure i'm thinking
that one of the post-credits scenes in
spider-man no way home could be about
venom and i'll break down everything you
need to know in this video and if news
like this is what you love consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news so let's start
off by talking about the fact that andy
circus the director of venom 2 confirmed
to the world the other day that venom
and spider-man are eventually going to
meet and fight as i mentioned he did an
interview with ign about venom let there
be carnage and of course he was asked
about spider-man in which he said this
everyone wants to know when venom is
going to meet spider-man personally it's
not going to happen i'm kidding it's
going to happen the question is when we
don't want to rush it so we no longer
have to wonder if it's going to happen
andy circus confirms right now it is
going to happen and about a month ago
tom hardy also came out and said that he
is going to push for venom 3 to be a
venom vs spider-man film in fact he said
he is going to do whatever he can do to
make that happen if the studios are on
board with it he compared spider-man vs
venom to an olympic gold medal and
basically said that's the goal that's
what you aim for the olympic gold medal
and he'd be crazy not to shoot for gold
so andy circus says that it's going to
happen and tom hardy says that he's
gonna do whatever he can do to make it
happen so i'm gonna assume it's gonna
happen and obviously they know more than
they're telling us and this could
actually affect spider-man no way home
or should i say spider-man no way home
could drastically affect venom vs
spider-man especially if you consider
the rumors going around about venom let
there be carnage's post-credit scene the
rumor is that the post-credits scene
will connect to tom holland spider-man
in some way shape or form and yes i have
heard all of the rumors about it in
detail i'm just not going into detail in
case some of those people out there
don't want those spoilers but if the
rumors end up being true and the venom
post credit scene does connect to tom
holland spider-man this does heavily
imply that the two of them are going to
meet and it actually applies that
they'll meet sooner rather than later
and here's the big news last night tom
hardy gave us more to look into he
posted a picture of himself wearing a
spider-man no way home hat that was
given to the crew of no way home so
things are getting a little bit more
curious now now this doesn't mean that
he's in the movie someone could have
just given this to him however
considering all this other information
that we've gotten recently there is a
possibility that he is in the movie and
if he is actually in the movie i have to
give them credit i guess because this is
the one secret that they were able to
keep from us although i guess if we're
talking about this and it ends up being
true it wasn't really a well-kept secret
so
yeah but there are actually a couple of
ways that venom could appear in
spider-man noway home that actually make
a ton of sense the first one is the post
credit scene obviously since it's a
marvel movie there are going to be two
post-credits scenes like almost every
other marvel movie out there spider-man
far from home had two post-credits
scenes so we can assume that it'll have
two one is obviously going to be about
doctor strange and setting something
serious up for the multiverse of madness
strange is a huge part of this movie and
obviously this movie jumps right into
the events of multiverse of madness so
it's gonna set that up somehow but what
could the other one be about well since
one will probably be about doctor
strange the other should be spider-man
related and since the venom let there be
carnage post-credit scene is rumored to
be about spider-man it would make sense
that the spider-man know a home post
credit scene could be about venom
especially if that is spider-man's next
movie because think about it let's say
everything comes true which i fully
believe it will but you never know but
let's say everything comes true toby
maguire shows up andrew garfield shows
up and we already know all of the
villains are going to show up and it's
all just going to be pretty epic so how
do you outdo that in the next film where
do you go from here well the one thing
that we wouldn't have seen in this movie
is venom spider-man finally going up
against venom this could be sony and
marvel's next move finally due with
spider-man vs venom film obviously the
director and tom hardy are thinking
about it which means the studios have
probably already been talking about this
especially if the rumors for venom let
there be carnage's post-credit scene are
true so this movie could be right around
the corner and perhaps we could be
seeing some sort of a setup in the
spider-man no way home post-credit scene
the other way that venom could appear in
spider-man no way home is that he could
be the sixth member of the sinister six
right now we only know five villains of
the sinister six all of which we kind of
saw in the trailer we have doc ock of
course we have the green goblin we have
electro we have sandman and we pretty
much know that that weird figure in the
dark creeping up behind peter is the
lizard we have no idea who the sixth
villain is even some of the leaks that
we've had that were pretty accurate say
that they don't know who the sixth
villain is could the sixth one be venom
is this why nobody knows who the sixth
villain is because it's such a big
secret because it's so big i admit that
this one is a little less likely to
happen and i wouldn't bet any money on
it happening but dang would it be cool
if venom was the sixth member because
you could totally have venom with all of
these other classic villains but then
you could still have a venomverse
spider-man film because this film could
set up the next one i personally would
really really love to see this but what
does it actually mean if venom does
cameo in spider-man no way home and even
if it is just a small cameo it does have
some huge implications especially if the
post credits of venom 2 do hint at
spider-man what does this mean are the
universes one now did the venom universe
suffer from the snap or did they somehow
get combined by whatever multiversal
effect is happening also you have to
keep in mind that the origin of venom
has completely changed from the comics
in the comics venom first bonds to
spider-man peter parker was the first
person to wear the venom symbiote in
1984 in the secret war storyline peter
parker wore the symbiote suit for a
while until it started to affect him in
a negative way then he parted ways with
the suit it then found its way to eddie
brock and it bonded with him and it
would hold a pretty big grudge against
spidey which is why venom despises
spider-man so much typically now
eventually venom goes on to become an
anti-hero but there is a lot of hate
towards spider-man in the beginning but
obviously this story didn't come
anywhere close to happening in the
spider-man universe over at sony will
venom still hate spider-man for whatever
reason do eddie brock and venom go to
new york to investigate this whole
spider-man mysterio who killed who case
from there does it lead to eddie working
with jay jonah jameson at the daily
bugle after all we have seen the daily
bugle in the venom let there be carnage
trailer so there is a connection there
could jay jonah jameson saying that
spider-man is a menace cause venom and
eddie brock to want to fight him and
stop him we do really have a lot of
endless possibilities here but that's
actually the really cool thing the
possibility of venom actually appearing
in spider-man no way home either in the
movie or in the post-credits scene but
let me know what you think about all of
this do you think that we're going to
see venom and spider-man no way home in
some way shape or form let me know what
you think in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof